[Music]
hey all right it's just me and grandpa's
in a chat oh it's so lonely in here yeah
that's all right we just keep gotta do
the show man gotta do the show well
that's oh now they're all showing up now
that's [ __ ] time
and time wants to show up well i guess
everybody knows it's like that we do
like the little five-minute
kind of run-up to it so they're just
kind of like why don't i want to sit
around for that i don't i don't blame
him maybe we should kind of quit doing
that yeah or maybe just do it like a
minute or something they're all they're
all they're all [ __ ]
pouring in now four throw downs in okay
this movie here
tom's just getting right into it right
down to this [ __ ] here
beverly hills cop three three
this movie here
okay
this is not a bad movie
but it's also not great okay
they really [ __ ] this one up
but this movie could easily be fixed
it's really only got a couple problems
with it the main problem is just tone
it does not have the same tone as the
other two
uh it's got
no soundtrack to speak of in a shitty
classical [ __ ] score
that kind of
apes the [ __ ] um uh uh [ __ ] bev
the hills cop one and two theme songs
you know like the actual foley theme
song
it's just man it's just not this movie
just was not made with care when it came
to
the sound the the score and the
soundtrack
i don't know if they got [ __ ] over on
licensing agreements well i think that
yeah i think what happened was that
harold faltermeyer who did axle f like
the main theme in the score for the
first one and the second one too i think
um i think he did not want to return uh
so they did actually use the axle f
theme in the third one but it was like a
cover version which i think nyle rodgers
had done yeah um so they did like a
bunch of different versions of it
including like a weird
sparky version yeah yeah they did that
they just said they did like some
variations on it just because they
couldn't get uh harold fault murray back
to do the original score other than that
there is some really good things about
this movie it's got a really cool
[ __ ] stunt scene it kind of took me
out of it a little bit with [ __ ]
eddie murphy saving some kids on the
damn big old [ __ ]
spider idea
which uh in the other two movies there's
never a hint of [ __ ]
that axel foley had
had that level of dexterity i mean [ __ ]
that a terrified [ __ ]
paratrooper or a special forces soldier
[ __ ] jumping from one [ __ ]
thing to the was straight up no thank
you
you kids yeah
i'm not jumping from the one to the
other yeah and that and that [ __ ]
stunt looked real looked like that dude
really did that
it did um honestly i mean obviously like
eddie murphy's part was like green
screened in which you could kind of
didn't look that bad but you could still
tell
um but yeah the way that like the long
shots of that stunt looked like the
actual stunt man was like actually
jumping
from
thing to thing and i i don't know if he
had some kind of like say i mean i'm
sure they had some kind of like [ __ ]
net or mattress or some kind of [ __ ]
underneath it
in case you fell yeah well you know well
you know i didn't mean mattress but i
mean like a big like a pad you know what
i mean like they have the
yeah
but you couldn't see it it wasn't in the
shot well yeah that's kind of like movie
magic yeah
they're probably been easier to hide a
a
a net
but uh anyway we're getting sidetracked
now we're still talking about the movie
yeah
uh it does take place in some pretty
[ __ ] um
weird locations inside of a theme park
uh the opening the opening scene of a
[ __ ]
swat team thing that they were gonna do
they were gonna make this bust in the
very beginning and they didn't call swat
because it was just mechanics they
thought they could handle it but when
they showed up they were getting whacked
by the mob basically and they got a big
[ __ ]
crossfire not with the mob but the bad
guys out of this movie
um
that was pretty cool scene it kind of
felt like the older movies had a good
good car chase in it
so some of the stunts and some of the
action and the firefights actually were
kind of
ramped up over the other two there was
more
but
it
it didn't seem like more and it was
because of the [ __ ] score
and the soundscape wasn't that good
um
the
a lot of it took place in the amusement
park and it has goofy [ __ ] amusement
park songs happening in the middle of
firefights it just doesn't
it doesn't fit the movie doesn't fit the
tone of the movie
it's been better had they just put
axel foley
theme song or
better i know they're trying to they
were trying to update the movie to them
because this is 94. it's quite yeah i
didn't realize that it was that much
later and then the second one quite late
so
the other two had pretty contemporary
music in it for the times that they came
out real hip [ __ ] so what would have
been hip in 94 [ __ ]
what what cold crunch
[Laughter]
[ __ ] uh there's a sound garden in
there yeah sound guard for allison
chains
uh it would have been [ __ ] like that
yeah what was going on
so you know
i'm too sexy for my shirt
what the year did that come out i mean
91-92 maybe ooh i'm too sexy yeah that
came out that i kind of feel like that
was maybe
1991. yeah that would have been
something that that that would have been
in an actual foley movie real poppy
big hit well i george michael's i want
your sex was in the second one which was
seven that's right in the strip club
scene that's right
which i think went a long way toward
like pushing that into the charts you
know yeah like being in that movie i
could think i forgot to mention that
like i think there was something about
licensing though they didn't want to
[ __ ] yeah because money away i feel
like this one i mean obviously the
budget for this one was way lower
because like i said beverly hills cop2
came out 1987. this one didn't come out
until 1994
and the movie that eddie murphy had done
prior to this
sort of tanked or it didn't do as well
as the as the studio was expecting so
the budget for this one got knocked down
so they're still gonna make it but they
didn't have as much money as they
thought they were gonna have right so
i kind of feel like yeah it doesn't have
any iconic music
um it still has the axle f theme but
it's like covers and like variations on
it instead of the actual one
and you know no pointer sister songs no
like catchy pop songs nothing like that
and
i was actually shocked i didn't realize
this i didn't realize that john landis
directed this
now john landis obviously he did uh he
did trading places and he did uh coming
to america so he had worked with eddie
murphy before that's what i mean and the
thing about it though is that john
landis like um you know they asked him
to direct this and he didn't like the
script at first but he was just kind of
like well i read the script and i
thought ah the script isn't that good
but we'll get eddie murphy in here and
he'll be funny he'll improv and it'll
fix it yeah so that's what he thought
but eddie murphy didn't do do that
really he seemed like he wasn't as funny
in this one
um he had his moments but
i was kind of reading like on the
wikipedia page they said there they had
done like an interview with um bronson
pinchot who plays serge
who's in this and he said um i kind of
feel like eddie murphy feels like uh his
last few movies hadn't done that well
and he seemed kind of like low energy
and like depressed um and i think that
kind of came across in his performance
uh as well
and another thing too is that when john
landis was like talking to him about
okay now we're gonna do like the fast
talking axel foley [ __ ] that everybody
loves and like tunes into this movie for
he kind of came eddie murphy kind of
said oh well this is this many years
later and i think alex full uh axel
foley would have like grown up by now
and been more mature so he's not gonna
do that as much
so i kind of feel like he played it like
two straight and that wasn't really i
mean he there were like some he did like
some funny fast talking [ __ ] like he did
in the old ones but not really that much
most of it he was just playing straight
or like not really telling any jokes or
anything yeah i was looking at this okay
what was the name what was the dude who
played surge
show yeah yeah his performance isn't
really spot on either
uh
when he did the high pitch stuff you can
tell that it you know what it is it did
not have that high energy cocaine
cocaine-fueled nature that's what i'm
saying
it seemed a little i think they were
jacked on coke
probably they were having a great time
and it was just and a lot of it was
improvisational
this one really seemed more scripted and
like they weren't it didn't seem as
natural or organic
part of it you know
when you're young and you're
maybe new into a project you know
[ __ ] you got you do have more energy
you feel on top of the world could be
they were slightly war world weary like
he said they were getting beaten down
from not having great movies back to
back a couple well yeah i think but you
can't get hung up on that you gotta
[ __ ] snap out of it and make a
[ __ ] comeback
but you know stress and [ __ ] worrying
about it can
pile on you know
so i i know what he's coming from i can
detect that now you said that yeah that
that's that's what's coming through that
is absolutely how he comes across in
this man because there are a couple of
scenes where he's still doing that his
eddie murphy thing
but most of it is just he's just playing
like pretty straight like a straight cop
that's just
i was gonna go back to serge's
his performance not only was performance
not really top-notch compared to you
know his other appearance
the edit isn't quite right
there's too much of him
a lot of his [ __ ] needs to be edited
down into quick sound bites that were
funny
and uh
that scene kind of dilly dallied a
little too much
and it kind of took the funniness away
because it went on too long it went on
too long the thing about surge what made
him funny is that he there was an
element of mystery to surge you don't
know much about him he's just this
strange gay dude in a [ __ ] well not
really strange he is strange you know uh
but he's
snotty a snotty gay dude in a uh art
gallery who's trying to be friendly to
you he's trying to be friendly he's
trying to offer you stuff but he in a
way is kind of looking down on you a
little bit that's how he come across to
me you know the fancy art guy
um
and you don't
that's what made that character great
you don't know a whole lot about it so
they leave you kind of wondering who is
that dude
you know yeah that's what made him
interesting you know
and in this one they kind of give you a
little too much of them
although it's not bad it just needed to
be
it needed to be about half that length
yeah i compressed i think the problem
too was that in the first one i think
what so like bronson pincha was really
funny in that
but i think a lot of the funny too came
from him his interaction or his
reactions yeah to eddie murphy and in
this one it seemed like i you know i
always want more of surge because i love
that character but
they he kind of goes on for a long time
and eddie murphy doesn't really react to
him he's just like standing there going
mm-hmm yeah like he's not there's no
like back and forth what's the fish out
of water angle yeah you know i mean
axel's a detective and he's very he's
detroit which is opposite from
from from [ __ ] beverly hills it's the
opposite
and this guy's from the art scene oh man
no that's [ __ ] totally opposite so
they don't really on the surface have
anything in common
and and that's what made that seem funny
yeah
um
now in this one there's more interaction
they kind of become friends but like i
said the scene is a little bit too long
it didn't have the punchy nature of your
first encounter with [ __ ] surge
yeah it was it you know it had that very
punchy nature and it happened fast every
time you saw him it was just over with
and he didn't have many lines and and it
actually it kind of but his delivery was
so good you remembered it that character
was super memorable yeah super memorable
which is why like i appreciated that
they brought him back for the third one
i just think that
you know and i even i you know even
though it's not super believable but
they bring it back in the third one like
he's at this like cop
uh he said he said he what is it like a
like a weapon it's like a gunshot
type of thing but like a high-end one
yeah it's uh it's it's it's an arm
supplier
and he's open like a boutique yeah and a
boutique with like with like fans like
weapons that are better like really
stylish in fact uh what it called
boutique urban survival right high-end
survival
so it was urban survival [ __ ] for rich
people and he was gone and he goes who
would buy this [ __ ] this [ __ ] gun
that had a cd player and a microwave and
[ __ ] yeah what was that called all
this [ __ ] i forgot man the annihilator
2 000 or something like that who would
buy this and he goes look at that
microwave had a microwave microwave oven
on it too it was good you could survive
and then yeah you could survive the
microphone was like this yeah
and um
that bit was funny like the fake
commercial for that was actually pretty
good he said she goes oh jackie stallone
bought do a four or five of them for
stocking stuffers sylvester stallone but
what do you think about ten of them
something you know yeah they can't keep
him in stock and he's like really
and then the gun makes an appearance
later on he needs a weapon search gives
him that floor model he goes yeah it's
all dirty so smelly and he hasn't
cleaned it up and shouldn't give it to
him he goes to fight the bad guys with
that thing and doesn't know how to use
it he plays music and [ __ ]
which is kind of funny but the
soundtrack and the [ __ ] score doesn't
match what's happening with the comedy
it doesn't enhance it
a lot of these a lot of these um
uh ad-libbed
ad-libbed [ __ ] things that that that
that eddie murphy does in this movie is
to like with no music no soundtrack at
all dead
and the the edit is a little bit too
long which kind of sucks the humor out
of it it didn't have the punchy nature
of the first two movies
it's just and it could be saved and edit
this movie could really be saved i'd
edit a lot of it down and make it a lot
tighter and put a really good score with
a lot of [ __ ] cool music in it a lot
of cool
songs from the time and then some
classic ones yeah i mean i think there's
enough good stuff in this that yeah it
could probably be salvaged yeah but
edit and music but honestly i think a
lot of this more like kind of more
serious [ __ ] with eddie murphy's
character could probably just be like
either cut out i mean obviously you
can't reshoot it but i don't know if
they did any different [ __ ] it just
seemed like he wasn't doing
all the improv like he was doing on the
old ones
and so there wasn't enough of that
of that axel foley character yeah in
there because so much of it was just
kind of like a straight detective story
it wasn't you know it wasn't quite as
funny like the interaction with him and
judge reinhold wasn't quite as funny and
it's just kind of like and john ashton
wasn't even in it
um you know taggart yeah and that all
they said was that oh he retired yeah
and uh they didn't even say what
happened to
uh bogamill he must have died um no well
he didn't want to do the movie yeah like
so he read the script and said no thanks
uh so but they don't even mention him in
the in the movie they mentioned taggart
they said they were retired but they
didn't mention uh bogama like what
happened to him so i thought that was a
little weird i think what you were
saying about some of the seriousness
that could have worked too if you'd had
the right music and the right score
because you could have made it real
serious deep and dark just for a few
minutes and then lighten it back up
again with something else like it
doesn't have it was weird the tone it
was just totally all over the place
trying to be funny when it wasn't really
that funny at certain times and then
trying to be serious but they'd have
goofy music going
it
yeah was a little
it could be this movie could be fixed
though because i mean a little bit
tighter edit better score i mean if you
haven't seen it again you know it's
because i kind of feel like by the third
time it's just like you know how is this
detroit cop how are we going to get him
to beverly hills it just seems like it's
kind of straining credibility at this
point but so what happens at the
beginning like i said the opening
sequence is actually pretty good
um where you know uh eddie murphy and
his team are like kind of uh they're
trying to like bust uh chop chop
and they think that it's just gonna be
like an easy bus they don't call swat
[ __ ] goes super sideways because there's
this other big or crime conglomerate
that's attached to it that they didn't
know about and uh
upshot of it is pretty much um his boss
uh todd gets killed
so uh he's gonna find the person that
killed todd and
it ends up that you know they are having
to do with this
theme park in beverly hills called
wonder world which is essentially kind
of like disney they kind of have like an
old like uncle dave he's kind of like
the guy behind it and they have all
these rides they actually have um some
of those rides because remember i said
when we were watching it like that one
ride where everybody's like shaking and
there's like the uh you know the road
like crashing down in there with the
truck and everything i said that looks
like the earthquake ride that used to be
it uh universal or mgm or whatever
because i remember riding that like in
orlando like years ago and when i looked
it up on wikipedia yeah they did
actually shoot the stuff inside of the
um inside of the earthquake ride at
universal uh in california
some of the other stuff like the
dinosaur ride at the end um they built
that like on a sound stage and some of
the stuff they shot like in a they asked
knott's berry farm but knott's berry
farm said no absolutely not you're not
shooting it here so some of the stuff
they built and some of this stuff was
like some other
like lesser-known theme park i guess
that they shot in but yeah so he ends up
going and finding out that like this
theme park is essentially
like the
isn't it like the security guards that
that work there
are like a private security company and
they're using the theme park as like a
front and then they're counterfeiting
yeah so it's like a counter they have a
laser printer right it's like a
counterfeit i know it's okay it's like a
counterfeiting 94 yeah and uh so they're
kind of like they have like a little
like counterfeiting shop like underneath
this closed ride yeah and it's like all
super top secret and everything and most
of the people that are like involved in
the security company
um know about it so it's just like this
big ring and so
uh axel foley is like trying he kind of
stumbles into that because the guy
that ended up that killed todd he
recognized him and he was like one of
the main guys from the security council
yeah the bad guys are basically uh you
know unremarkable they just yeah they
just don't stand out at all another
thing about the movie that kind of
missed
i think
like i said this movie's a miss it's not
a disaster though if you if you liked
the first two it's worth seeing
it's just okay
it's not great it's not terrible it's
just okay it's some extra stuff
it looks like it feels like it was
the tone is wrong it was kind of like it
was cobbled together to make some money
that's that's what it felt like um
but there is some good [ __ ] in it
you know it has its moments
yeah the movie could be fixed i didn't
mind some of the stuff like some of the
[ __ ] was funny uh i liked uh hector
alizado's character who is basically the
taggart stand-in yeah uh he was funny
but even like judge reinhold i j i
generally i i didn't realize how much i
missed the taggart character until he
wasn't there yeah like as good as hector
elizondo is in it
um i kind of liked the trio you know of
eddie murphy and judge reinhold and john
ashton they played off each other so
well because they were all three of them
were so different
and uh once you don't have that
it's just kind of like i don't know
there was just like something missing
and even judge reinhold seemed like he
wasn't in it all that much
and he wasn't um i don't know he just
was it didn't seem as funny like i said
the interactions just weren't as funny
they weren't as natural or as organic
and some of the [ __ ] like i said like
the stuff with surge and like i'm not
[ __ ] on the search character because
i love serge but um it just it needed to
be like tightened up yeah and there
needed to be more interaction between
serge and eddie murphy rather than eddie
murphy just standing there listening to
surgery
right yeah you know yeah they need to do
something yeah they need to like bounce
off one another because that's what was
funny about the first one is they were
like reacting to one another and they
weren't really doing that in this yeah
he was just like serge was basically
just like giving a sales pitch of like
his stuff which like i said was funny
but
you know
then they'd cut to eddie murphy and he'd
be like oh yeah cool you know what i
mean
there wasn't really any kind of like i'm
gonna stick with my original statement
though this movie if you were to re-edit
this movie and put a good soundtrack in
it a really good score this movie would
be twice as good as it is
i mean it's not fatally flawed the main
problem is the edit and the soundscape
yeah they improve it a lot
would it be as good as the other two no
no no uh
i would have done it differently
i wouldn't have brought him back to
beverly hills
i would have had axel get in trouble
there in detroit
and then
had i would have had something like i
would have had rosewood
um
come from beverly hills
to help
yeah see that would have been kind of
cool this if you'd set one in detroit so
you now got the beverly hills cop in
that one would be to uh rosewood
rosewood would be that would be the
beverly hills cop again see that would
have been a good switcheroo because then
you would have had like a beverly hills
cop coming to detroit and it would have
been again you would have the fish out
of water but opposite right they should
have been listening to me but i was you
know
and i've done it that way and then um
that way you could try to get some
licensed bob secret [ __ ] or whatever
some detroit [ __ ] music or something
yeah
i don't know you know
94
they probably felt look we shouldn't go
retro because you know i mean like and
that wasn't that long ago
yeah you can't do retro until it's like
a while
[Laughter]
but uh you could have made a real good
90s
soundtrack
in detroit late mid 90s 94 man you could
have done some really cool goth type
[ __ ]
a couple goth type songs like something
out of the crow
because there's a goth scene going on
there you could do rap
uh there you could do um house music
they did a lot of that in detroit during
that time but i kind of feel like some
of the ones
because it was nile rogers i feel like a
lot of it was kind of like r b which is
fine
but you know niall rogers he did [ __ ]
with [ __ ] everybody he worked at
duran duran too like back in the 80s but
um i don't know i just kind of feel like
i don't think grunge would have worked i
don't think honestly i think that it
would have been better
kind of going with the first couple
movies if they'd had just done like pop
music like the pop music that was on
which i can't even remember what was
popular in 1994 it would have been
garage but i don't see i don't know that
no because there was still pockets you
know there was still pop music in 1994
techno maybe they should have done that
or i don't know i don't really know how
it would have worked but i it's it's
kind of hard for me to say because
i mean i didn't hate this movie i just i
thought it was just like kind of low
energy yeah yeah but you could have had
so much fun shooting this in detroit all
those damn abandoned buildings and
everything maybe they'll do that for the
fourth one yeah you could have some bad
ass [ __ ] bad guys centered around
detroit kind of like did with the crow
um and you could [ __ ] actually burn
down and blow up houses because they had
[ __ ] abandoned [ __ ] everywhere
and then you could bring the
there was like all kinds of cool [ __ ] uh
the the the abandoned subways in detroit
abandoned skyscrapers they could have
had a lot of fun down there it wouldn't
cost them that much to make that there
and uh i ought to put it to detroit made
it to detroit yeah i think that would
have been probably best yeah because
showing actually in his element
yeah because then that way and then you
don't have the problem of like i said
straining control to being like oh
really is this dude having to go out to
beverly hills again like for the third
time it's like no one's gonna believe
that yeah um you know what i'm saying
like why are all these people from
beverly hills coming to detroit and
[ __ ] [ __ ] up because what's funny is
that every scene in this movie that was
shot in the detroit felt a lot more like
beverly hills cop didn't it
it did yeah
honestly i kind of liked the opening
scene could have done without the weird
um
the weird like uh dancing scene like
with the two criminals at the beginning
like it wasn't super long it wasn't the
whole song
like two seconds what's up what that was
the supreme supreme song yeah yeah that
should have been one or two seconds long
yeah that let them know again like it
just everything went on like a little
bit too long like so if it was that was
supposed to be funny but it just went on
like too long for it to be funny yeah if
that had been like one second a second
where they both turned around at the
same time and did like a dance move and
then they cut away yeah yeah that would
have been hilarious a lot more funny but
don't do it for like a minute right
because i was just like why are we
having a dance for now or what is this
all about why would you do that
but the scenes that took place in
detroit that tonally felt a lot more
like the other first two movies it was
when it went back to wally world or
wherever that [ __ ] place was wonder
where wonder world yeah [ __ ] it up i
would have shot that [ __ ] in detroit and
made that a [ __ ] hardcore
blade runner-esque type [ __ ] movie
i must say i did like the scene where uh
where eddie murphy was in the okey dokey
elephant suit yeah and like pushed that
little kid into the fountain like that
was funny yeah but honestly that scene
should have gone that scene was like
super super short but it should have
gone on a little bit longer yeah you
know what i mean where he like punched
the kid or something that would have
been hysterical
then like have the grandma come over
there and be like you deserved it or
whatever but it's like yeah it just
seemed like the jokes that were not all
that funny went on too long and the
jokes were actually funny weren't long
enough or there wasn't enough of them it
was just i don't know it was just a very
very strange experience i thought
that maybe i had seen it back in the day
but nothing seemed familiar the only
thing that was familiar to me from this
movie was from the beginning where he
knocks on the door of the warehouse and
says is this the illegal chop shop and
i'm thinking maybe i remember that just
because it was from the trailer yeah
because that was literally the only
thing i didn't remember anything about a
theme park or anything like that
could also done without the love
interest
um because you didn't have that in the
other two really and um you know i could
have done without it and this one it was
just kind of like underdeveloped and it
just didn't really need to be in there
you know that woman that uh that worked
in the theme park you know graham's
asking me about black water i got offers
from that man back in [ __ ]
95 back before i even knew what that was
and that [ __ ] sounded so sideways and so
shady and they wouldn't answer any
questions i [ __ ] turned it down i had
no idea what that was in 95.
then by the time
we knew then it was all it's already
stuff i worked for companies that
trained
foreign
police and foreign soldiers but
like i said the
these are contracts that
go through the state department a lot of
times for companies that only exist
for that mission and they shut down and
then it'll form again or another one
will form again under another name the
blackwater's mistake was is that you
know its name
all right
what that used to be or blackwater is
now a bunch of other companies that are
constantly opening and closing opening
and closing that's part of its
camouflage you'll so
it would take me a while but i could
find it
but i wouldn't want to get involved in
that man told that [ __ ] and then
look what they'd have you do
you know
and then wagner group you know something
called wagon but wagner i would never
work for wagner all right [ __ ] half
the dudes in that [ __ ] group right
there
they're ukrainian and ukrainian and
russian dudes with ss runes and [ __ ]
death heads on them [ __ ] nazi deaths
heads it's a lot of [ __ ] people don't
realize of what they're like you know in
that part of the world i wouldn't deal
with it
slasher fred points out that this movie
also started john saxon yeah i forgot to
mention that he's actually one of the
one of the bad guys and uh i want to say
too because john landis directed it and
uh john landis is kind of well known for
putting his friends like other directors
as cameos uh so joe dante turns up in
this as does jon singleton uh and ray
harryhausen was in there too of all the
[ __ ] people i think he was in that
bar scene uh but yeah yeah gramphther
says have rosewood working the streets
of detroit as ghetto dogs carry limbs
down the street of dead drug addicts
they found abandoned homes yeah they
could go to one of the strip bars strip
bars along eight mile road a stripper
could snort blow off roads with schlong
in the broom closet as axle box yeah see
that's a movie that i would watch see
greg grabs i would watch your detroit pd
i don't remember where it was i think i
think you said it was detroit
but uh
now i'm kind of curious because
as far as i know they're still making
the fourth one right i mean they've been
talking about that since 2015. well
rumored that that's the next one well
last i heard i don't know if this is
still the case but like in 2019 or 2020
they were talking about uh that the
fourth one was going into pre-production
after coming to america the second one
so i don't actually know if they're
gonna make it or not but honestly if
they did i think they should do like the
switcheroo thing oh okay because like
where'd they go to detroit i mean i
think that would be better yeah okay if
they could get everybody back again i
know probably everybody's old as [ __ ]
now but you know what i mean yeah
uh yeah grantham said no i was a federal
agent
yeah all right yeah i think he said that
yesterday actually
but yeah so
so i don't know it's just kind of like
there was just something very odd about
this movie and it's really
that's why i was like so shocked that
john landis had directed it because him
and eddie murphy had worked together a
lot before
um you know on some great [ __ ] movies
and so it just seemed like this one
i don't know like i said i think some of
it is attributable to the direction the
editing mostly but i think a lot of it
is attributed to like eddie murphy just
not
seeming like he was that super into it
like he's just really not
he seems kind of like bummed out it
seems kind of and even like at the time
like the reviewers were like this is a
very depressing
film it's very joyless it doesn't have
like a lot of the energy like the other
ones had and he just seems like he's
playing the character mostly straight
which is not really what you want to see
from this character so i kind of felt
that like through the whole thing like i
said there's some good [ __ ] in it but
i don't know it was just something and
there was like some good stunts like the
whole stunt like on the spider ride and
everything like that that was like a
good sequence
although it went on a little bit too
long like a lot of the sequences did in
this but i mean it wasn't terrible it
just wasn't
i don't know there was just something
like really
i think that the time for that had
passed by that point you know what i
mean because it was so much later like
after the second one and i just kind of
feel like they had missed the window
of opportunity and everyone was just
kind of like sick of it
at that point and they were just kind of
like bad [ __ ] it and it's just you know
but
what are you gonna do it's it's not as
bad as everyone says although i will say
that on rotten tomatoes i noticed it has
nine percent
which is pretty bad pretty bad it's not
that bad it's not yet well you know like
i said i was you know i'm a big mystery
science theater fan so i've seen like oh
yeah i probably like i could think of a
hundred movies right now that are like
way worse than this one but um you know
it just wasn't
it didn't have that magic the other two
are eights and nines this one's more
like a six four or five yes
and i think i think the reaction is the
disappointment from the fans
yeah that's what that's mostly yeah i
mean i think they waited too long
um they made the character too
mature
you know it didn't have that same zing
it didn't have
a lot of the character interaction that
made the other ones so good like a lot
of the improvisational
stuff and it's just you know so it just
kind of it felt a little like flat and a
little lifeless you know what i mean it
looked okay like it like it was shot
fine and everything like that but it's
edit and soundscape yeah i think
honestly the editing and the and the
kind of like tone of it just being like
a little bit too serious it's like it's
weird because it's almost like too
serious but then too goofy like it
needed a better balance
there's like really really goofy [ __ ]
and then most and then it's like really
serious and it just doesn't really work
all that well you know yeah but uh uh oh
we're going red
no it came back it came back okay it was
just a second yeah that must have just
been our the whole house like yeah
[ __ ] thing but yeah it came back
uh so yeah are we done talking about
beverly hills cop3
yeah we sounded real enthused about this
it's not that bad it's not terrible it
wasn't as bad as i was expecting
but
it was yeah it was a little bit of a
trial to sit through gotta say a little
bit because it just
yeah graham so guys guys who had the eod
credentials did all the classworms work
stuff
most of your dudes that kind of had
infantry type experience did all the
[ __ ] range and field stuff you know
running the ranges blowing [ __ ] up
picking up stuff teaching how to [ __ ]
pick things up making grids in the
ground
all the [ __ ] hands-on [ __ ] but then
the dudes with the eod [ __ ]
credentials you know they're kind of
like our versions of commissioned
officers they were the ones that were
[ __ ] making all the money
[Laughter]
but that's how it always is
we do the work they do all the money
they get all the money look at that [ __ ]
oh my creepy phone's ringing yeah
telemarketers but uh it probably says
spam wrist that [ __ ] is always [ __ ]
spooky though because you teach one
thing but then it can be reversed into
something else and then [ __ ] happens and
you go what was that the intent so you
get real suspicious
state department [ __ ]
yeah all right so i'm getting kind of
hungry
okay yeah it's about dinner time i think
all i'm eating today is a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich yeah it's like not
not really i got that curry down there
oh okay that'll be good yeah all right
so uh yeah it's tuesday so which means
tomorrow is the main show yeah uh we're
gonna be doing the grinder killer and uh
some other online murderers um gonna
keep it to like maybe three or four so
it's the show's not like super long but
somebody requested that we do the
grinder killer so
so i'm gonna do that and maybe like
throw in a couple other
internet-based uh serial killers as well
so that should be fun slash horrifying
uh so yeah be sure to drop by tomorrow
evening at 5pm and thanks for dropping
by today we will see you again tomorrow
bye